[Musique]
pour ce personnage de brevets
on a encore un livre qu'on aura qu'on
appuie pour un autre chasseur en
gaspésie sur la montagne bloqué puis il
ya un autre époque
faut vraiment je le crains faudra faire
un nom un autre chasseur un autre
personnage donc ce que j'ai découvert le
poids taille cette fois de le dire mais
pour faire pour avoir un autre physique
avec lui sur les progrès sont faits en
gel de silicone d'un front les les deux
joueuses et puis on voit comment que
c'est vraiment de vraiment flexible si
on voit au niveau de la comac s'est
donné aussi je vieillis aussi présente
et bien préservé la gonzesse par s'est
vu que je sais faire que ça enfin la
chanson puis au logis nous sur ce
captivant t de l'hydra d'histoire comme
ce puits
c'est ce qu'on sait pas que ce qui avait
de l'air physiquement cela des
squelettes qui reste seul con qui
découvrent si vous faites du tas mais
artistiquement c'est on essaie de
visualiser où je suis un gentil avec les
photos des détenus est aujourd'hui les
amérindiens vraiment le personnage
crédible at il pour pour des séries
comme ça
[Musique]